est ce que tu penses que côtier par ton
père tu peux me battre oui c'est sûr
mike tu la coach je vais jouer contre ta
fille y les gars je vais lancer une
balle dans le public
je vous le dis similan me bats la
personne ne repartira avec 5000 euros
d'accord similan perd malheureusement ce
sera perdu d'accord on fait ça en cinq
points l'accord millan il ya un petit
cours on a installé un petit cours
dehors
ok on joue trois contre moi et c'est ton
papa qui va de coacher ok mike tu la
coach quatre mois tu sais que j'étais
champion de tunisie - le nova tu ne
viens pas donc tu as peur de moi c'est
arrivé j'ai lu direct live id arrivée
était enfouie qu'après ma bulle ap hm je
sens que je vais pas faire le beau avec
lully ça peut partir très vite à la
houppe à mike il a vu que j'étais
tonique il a vu ça peut partir à tout
moment
alors attention c'est parti à l'essai
comment mater baaba maal et c'est parti
les chéris
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Musique]
à
des petits tracas des données 2000 en
quatre mois
point nous donner des vallées chéri allé
les pêcher mais il attendra alors match
et les gars là alors oui tout va bien
valérie comment tu t'appelles je
t'appelle bénisse amy terrible si
similan me bats en cinq pointures partir
avec 5000 euros machine alors sinon les
remettra en jeu pour demain d'accord
bébé venez tous vous pouvez appeler
alors attention c'est parti mais toi là
ma chérie mais toi la ja ja millan qui
se prépare mylan en 5.1 vachiery hockey
fight night
mais qu'est ce que tu as des conseils à
lui donner garde le bien en ligne de
fond d'accord le bien en ligne de fond
ok tu vois que tu sois quelqu'un bat
vraiment j'espère alors on est arrivé on
a du mal à mettre des baskets là
attention c'est parti
mais chérie tu veux faire quelques
balles avec - mike non je ne sais pas je
jouais pas je t'ai vu jouer tu joues pas
mal attention c'est parti très mauvais
et la tpr est en fait une petite balles
d'échauffement
allez c'est bon mais là non les gars on
va pas s'en sortir avec ses baskets
le maïs est raffermie alors moi je veux
dire la vérité
si je gagne c'est toute ma vie dès que
tu feras nintedo tu seras quelque part
tu diras je suis fort mais le plus fort
ça reste quand même bah oui c'est c'est
un vrai t'as peur c'est fait merci j'ai
fait attention
c'est beau mullan millan canaux van bon
si je perds j'arrête le tennis a bien
voulu lier tout de suite racaille et
j'arrête on arrête les conneries là ça
fait 25 ans que je m'emmerde avec ce
sport un kino mamère nqi le mans mène
que des soucis
1 c'est ben les chéris moyens et le gac
qui met les baskets il travaille chez
foot locker on voit le sourire à leur
niveau
calme-toi quand même hein mais elle vaut
ce qui la met dans le court et il ya les
limitant à melano niveau en trois points
fait pote hockey fait pas de servir est
à ta pas trop faim c'est bon ma chérie
mike tu veux lui dire un truc n'a
toujours pas trop fort passons sur la
coiffure
et ses gaffes de horst rue maillol ces
truites arabe et la map el mellah bat la
chamade la forêt musicale éponyme bon
aura 10 à 0 pour toi allez c'est parti
non ces fautes faciles à un partout
abattant je fais pas les séguin en a
[ __ ]
aussi j'ai moi aussi moi aussi j'ai des
enfants des garçons de bonjour trois
points mais en trois points auxquels est
belle tu as les balles de match ok c'est
la balle de match
ok mullan mike
match ball
[Applaudissements]
mais tu te fous moi j'adore david millar
se
le vrai que mike je me joue avec elle à
loin to play oui weaver d'accord à
roland garros je vais jouer avec elle et
là je peux te dire tu vas voir qu'ils
ont montré la vidéo parce que là elle
m'a elle m'a énervé qui peut battre la
famille tyson et ben on a vu que ça ils
sont très fort en ce sens lui et c'est
un druide ou